so what happens in these things is that
technology comes out it's happening now
we're deeply everyone says if I don't
get hold of this technology and build up
a group within my company that knows how
to do it then I'm going to be left
behind
so they start investing in the
technology without any evidence that it
actually works to solve their problem on
the assumption that if they don't
they'll be left behind this this there's
a potential gain here oh we can't afford
to lose it and then they start to hear
stories but all this other company you
know they tried six times and if just
fails - I didn't work for their problem
then they start to lose faith very
quickly all those companies that haven't
yet had a success can switch overnight
from thinking it's essential - we better
get out of this otherwise we're going to
look foolish so that's sort of what
happened with the expert system in the
late eighties which is a shame because
by then right we already had the
technological solutions that would have
alleviated a lot of those difficulties